And I would give this is Dr. Connor section 12 of the stop fighting cancer book. Yeah, there's a
lovely little picture of me down there
And that was how I kept it really small
Yeah, there was a purpose in there. We're looking at treating the cause of the cancer and this section
We're talking about healing your gut barriers all your barriers. So
Special brain cancer, we want to heal your blood brain barrier as well
But in all cancers, you know the difference that we look at in our clinic is that we're not
Looking solely at okay, so if person comes in with liver cancer, we're gonna treat that liver cancer
No, we got to treat the person's body
So what causes the liver to function? Well the brain does you have to also treat the brain
So in dealing with this you have to look at different barrier systems
So you have barrier systems in your body. They give them as walls that protect you
So obvious what is your skin so you can spill things on your skin and you don't blow up when you wash the dishes
Because you have a barrier this epithelial skin layers that help protect the outside world for the inside world inside your tissues
Well, so it is with your gut your gut is a barrier
Actually what's inside the lumen of your intestines is in the outside world
What's the inside world is your bloodstream and your gut tissue and your and your cell structure?
So normally you have a lining in your gut that protects from
Absorbied bad things into your body
So if I had a perfectly healthy gut lining and I swallowed mercury from the mercury thermometer would that be harmful to me?
Well, yes, it would probably damage my gut lining. However, I really should have absorbed it. I shouldn't absorb that mercury
The problem is is when I have a what's called a leaky gut or a fascial that we call it a testinal
Perviability, so when those tight-gap junctions of the intestinal cells are
Separated because of poor diet genetically modified food the number one and
In chemical exposure, you know gluten sensitivity and flammatory
Foods that we eat that cause this inflammation of the gut and cause damage to these these epithelial cells
It causes the misseparate out and things get across into our bloodstream that never should have. That's
Laman's term that's called leaky gut that causes food intolerance is it causes immune abnormalities?
It's a major cause of autoimmune conditions and
There's no way
That we want to cancer patient dealing with this at the same time. They're trying to heal
Cancer in their liver, so you have to take a whole listic
Viewpoint when you're gonna treat anybody with a name disease. That's part of my little gripe against
Against the current medical professionals that they take a systems approach. I mean, oh, you have
Problems with your kidney. Well, then you go to the real specialist. Oh, you have problems with your cola
And then we're gonna send you to the gastrointestinal specialist
Well, hello, but you are
Interconnected everything in your body is an intra relationship. It is not you cannot separate it out
No, you need a specialist on the GI track. What controls the GI track the brain is a control by the liver
Yes, it is is the as the kidneys have a function it does the spleen the heart et cetera
They're all interrelated. So when you just separate them out and look at your body through a microscope
You cannot see this interrelationship that's so important
That's what a holistic point of view is you need to take a step back and look at this
So it is even if a person has liver cancer you want to work on healing these barriers. They're so important
So this picture talks about the gut barrier, but you also have a barrier in your brain called the blood brain
barrier
very important barrier because
What actually controls the healing of all cells your brain does so your brain is in communication with all these tissues
And that's what stimulates a healing reaction if you're in a sympathetic dominant state
It's going to be very difficult for you to heal you could be a sympathetic dominant state
From an inflammatory process that's going on in the brain decreasing the frontal lobes ability to communicate to inhibit deep
brain
Centers that then put this person in a limbic state and they're dealing with liver
Cancer it's going to be very difficult to do to heal liver cancer when I'm stuck in a sympathetic dominance
So healing the blood brain barrier and looking at inflammatory markers in the brain are so important
That's why it's it's very difficult to
to
Have a patient and just treat them from an ecological standpoint
You tend to treat them from a holistic standpoint. You're just going to get better results. So
Hope this section helps you understand this
So a lot of these things are addition in addition to the written book. So
You're going to get a little bit more benefit out of this little course
So again if you have questions call our office if I'm speaking too fast listen to it again read this section
I hope it's a lesson to you and I'll see you soon